what is your name alice what do you want to
say
at least to me the torment of the mariupol people
so I’m for this
[music] the
heart of the innocent began
password
here we surrendered, but it was to ensure at
that moment that the knee was
shelling and our market was already unpleasant
for the club,
we try
not to be nervous and when they shoot at the
structure it cracks
[music]
it means that my
situation there is difficult and maybe
tragic,
but
it’s just me, in fact, today I was
talking to the presidential bard
gunn, he was talking about what is there
fighting is going on there is no fighting is
not over
[music] the
proposed assault on the
industrial zone I consider
it inappropriate I
order to cancel block this
industrial zone so that the enemy fly
[music]
we need to evacuate from here we are
civilians this is what happened already the spoon
was rest behind the pub very near  and new
tint
[music]
I am the commander of the Azov regiment, lieutenant colonel
dennis prokopenko  so
light and tariff right at a time at the
Azovstal plant come in hundreds of civilized
romadins from relatives rich in children and again a
puppy sprue of people of some families
defenders near Mariupol of these Uvays and the sight of the
Russian world in the basements there is a bomb with
vegetables a guy in Ukrainian visco you
wash  to continue the planets, places he is
unnecessary secret, you can jump there the
Russian occupier is to the laboratory assistants of the hall of the
DPR with the knowledge of knowing it is cleaner here the civilian is not
when I am aviation is not against the bunker not
bombs will fire missiles this is all she is
obvious or creatures bombarded with,
including the Drama Theater soon  the
bottle lair of the liqueur school, not the girlish
garden, was cured, and you, we
should bespeco about the puna, then you can
evacuate the entire evacuation, no one is sure to show-off tomoya,
for clicking the politics of the entire civilized
retinue, organizes and the green corridor must be
a guarantee bespeco training to carry out the
evacuation of the civilian wounded, then the bodies of the
dead  warriors and timide but i bad not
with honors
[music]